chanter
toute la troupe l'aude de pétanque animé
dans le monde entier doit voyager alors
d'eric avec novikova temps donné
mais on a trop tôt là tout est permis
alors toi aussi
aujourd'hui ce qui nous dit que dans 10
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous le visage
bouger plus la mer alors ça va bien
aussi
allez ça va bien c'est récré a2 et
aujourd'hui nous vous invitons à visiter
le camping doha crade
oui alors là je suis très surpris je
vais demander à jacques tu liêm pippen
camping sympa mois d'octobre je
m'inquiète je m'inquiète beaucoup
et oui abonde excusez moi je pense que
cela maintenant l'attention des seniors
je peux vous parler de doha m ce
traitement ça va tout seul je vous
disais donc que j'étais prête à trouver
inquiète ce contrat qui donne des
conseils en général on se retrouve dans
du béton d'enduro wec ya cette voix est
là on va félicitations je ne sais pas
comment tu as fait c'est superbe c'est
beau ça te plaindre océan ben oui du
soleil tous ces trains jusqu'à nous il
ya cinq ans c'était aussi supérieur à la
gamescom septième mort c'est pas très
beau à tout et bien selon attendre il ya
un petit problème vient juste un petit
problème c'est que j'ai oublié les
piquets de tente
l'attentât oui voilà le nouveau jeu
signé j'ai oublié notre mini jeux et
balle et jouent bien et ben c'est fini
de quoi enfin l'époque n'avait pas pu
disputer ici non mais je leur ai vu mais
oui les nuls c'est aussi mon fils est en
vacances il fait bon c'est marie curie
dont il ya plein d'activités à faire ici
une annonce plutôt moi qui regarde moi
ça quand quand un petit voleur vous
répondre que le style à 12h 20m qui vole
un âne deux vaches désolé c'est l'erreur
de 2,4 à nice
enfin vous savez rien mais autre chose
ça alors il ya autre chose qu un tournoi
de boules j'organise un combat de boules
à 2h25 alors champions non alors non
possible et nous avons rendez vous avec
le premier épisode de johan et pirlouit
ca oui c'est pas du tout ça c'est comme
les chocs en tout cas c'est le même pas
passé peyo faisant appel à l'armée
notez-bien super mais qu'à cela ne
tienne pas leurs quatre matches est la
nôtre alors rendez vous à la plage pour
faire de la planche à voile à allons
avoir un set à sens et nous a donné
rendez vous battre officielle donc la
variable j'aimerais avoir une petite
partie de pêche à 14h45 on est là avec
marabout de ficelle
alors s'il ya but alors j'ai un copain
j'ai un copain qui me prête sont hors
bords au près peut-être aller faire un
peu de ski nautique en contiennent deux
dans leur dos non désolé tu te vois lot
alors une petite boule en 5h03 heureux
qu'arne tous baulois c'est pas possible
à 3,04 parce qu'il ya là tu ne les relie
je suis sûr de gagner cette fois ci
c'est pas possible
voilà on est désolé que vous faites
votre choix en quatre heures le tour du
monde en 80 jours j attaque enfin la
bande à dd alors vos activités
c'est pas mal et naleo pour tous car je
trouvais un fichage du coup ça jacki
théâtre reçoit dans les campings sont
pas seuls on a peu partout où que vous
soyez si la baisse des prix dans la
tente à côté de la route